okay is this the way I want to present
myself first thing in the video yep sure
good morning I am down in Palm Springs
visiting my parents who have been
staying down here for the last few weeks
um to visit and to help us with the
house fix some things up this is their
last weekend so I'm down here shipping
them out to New Jersey but I'm currently
just like my teenage years stowed away
in a bedroom on my computer I'm editing
this Vlog and I realized this Vlog is
just all over the place so I may as well
introduce that and let you know this is
just an amalgamation of Random clips
from the last three weeks um as I get
into radiation so please enjoy the
absolutely haphazard and clumsy story
telling that
awaits man yeah what a look huh it's
7:45 a.m. and we're on our way to go
meet with the radiologist for the first
time and our oncologist and get updated
labs and as I was trying to get into the
car this morning I opened the car door
into my face and got my forehead
open so now I'm walking into the
oncology building explain it again go
into more detail I was holding a bunch
of stuff in my hands a tea a water a bag
full of all the things I think I need
when I leave the house my minimal amount
of eyelashes cause my eyes to fill with
water as soon as I get out in the cold
air and when I open the car door I had
no
awareness physically of how close I was
to the car door and I opened it directly
into my forehead and the top of the car
door just scraped across my forehead and
Elliot just said oh baby you're
bleeding now we're ready to go to the
doctor's office is a good thing we're
going to a medical building hey what a
fun way to meet my radiologist for the
first
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
hello let's see how that goes that works
a little bit we're on our way to get a
CT scan simulation body mapping thing
basically I'm getting my body scanned so
that they can lay out a map for
radiation treatment once I go get my
body scanned it'll take about a week for
them to develop the bath behind the
angles in which the radiation will go
into my body on a daily basis so it hits
the marks and does not affect my other
organs hooray once the treatment starts
it's going to be 20 days Monday through
Friday every day I'm going to get some
real alone time going in this car maybe
we'll start car vlogging I don't know
though my ability to do do multiple
things at once has severely decreased
I'm upset that this person isn't
turning like it's hard for me to have
road rage right now and talk to you guys
damn it this light let's go get our body
map let's go again take our shirt off in
a room of medical
[Music]
professionals okay we did it we got our
body map they put some little tattoo
dots on my body which I think are actual
tattoos I've been thinking about getting
a tattoo from this experience and I
think I just got four of them they keep
saying they're going to put tattoo dots
on you and then they have a vibrating
gun and they tell you that it's going to
pinch so it's like yeah that's not
tattoo as in like this is like a tattoo
I think it is a tattoo they mapped me I
went in a big machine I came out of the
machine and then I go back next Tuesday
for our first safety run and then we
begin everyday radiation woo woo hello
good morning I spilled tea on myself
it's 7:45 a.m. I'm going back to Caesars
to get an echo cardiogram I've had two
of them before in the past they are
super easy and awkward measuring your
heart to make sure your heart's not
having any malfunctions you go into a
room you put a gown on and then you lay
on a table and you turn towards the
technician and your boob rests on like a
a little shelf that pops out of the
table that you're laying on and you're
just kind of face to face with the
technician as they measure your heart
under your gown with your boob resting
on a little shelf that pops out from the
side of the table for about 45 minutes
yeah last time I gave myself permission
to not have to make small talk you know
this is where my ability to dissociate
comes in so
[Music]
handy okay wow that was so so easy and
not as awkward as the last two times I
had a lovely woman doctor nurse
technician who was totally Pleasant and
just talked me through everything she
was doing which made the length of time
that I'm sitting looking at her with one
boob flopped out much less awkward so
the room they make it dark so that the
ultrasound can see the images better I'm
so sleepy now I think my heart looked
okay I forget to ask post to my
oncologist and I forget to ask in the
moment just like that looked okay right
I just assumed that they would tell me
otherwise ignorance is bliss except it's
not Bliss it's just like
anxiety quiet anxiety I think it's fine
all right let's just get in traffic and
go home okay this is the current state
of my hair after I shower look at this
mullet that I have going isn't this wild
a lot of the hair seems to have fallen
out on the sides but here's the best
news this was the first time I took a
shower and not a [__] ton of hair fell
out as I brushed it afterwards so
hopefully we're coming to the end of the
shedding process has been 7 weeks since
my last chemo appointment they say
shedding lasts up to 2 Months 8 weeks
after your last chemo round so this
hopefully hopefully we're towards the
end and then I can go and get it just
like cut short so that everything can
start growing back but it's going to be
my natural brunette hair color for a
while cuz I don't think I can dye it for
a few months and we got some gray hairs
com in the front you know don't love to
see them but they're there quite a
current hair status not terrible but
definitely strange look at this [__]
Billy Ray
Cyrus good morning just getting ready
for my 9:00 a.m. sex toy integration
photo
shoot she's got a brand deal this year
expect the unexpected hello I suppose
all Vlog been vlogging very
intermittently I just went and had a
lovely breakfast with the one the only
Hank Green what a great guy Hank has
always been one of those people that you
just want to talk to and you feel like
you could talk to them for hours and now
especially I feel like we have so many
things that we could talk about for
hours and hours and hours but it was a
very lovely wonderful time and now I'm
getting ready to go over to mayor's
place because we have added a second
episode of this might get weird every
week called this might get real that is
solely focused on reality television and
currently we are talking about the Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City Reunion and
the new season of rupal's drag race if
you're unaware please go over to
youtube.com/ thism mightet and check out
the video versions on Fridays for this
might get real so so far it's a really
lovely day I got to talk to Hank and I
get to go over to memories and talk
about reality TV this is
a [__] great day for all hell big
talking about Lisa's husband John and
she was like what' I say about John and
then it was quiet and then Angie goes
you called him a penis
head and everyone's and then Heather
goes why would you call him a penis
head so many why would you call him a
penis head you called him a penis head
why would you call him a
[Music]
penis
it's not
working
[Music]
hello good day we are going to radiation
this is not the first official day this
is a safety run those tattoos that they
put on me bing bing bing bing all four
of them we are going to see if the math
that they have done in the meantime
lines up I'm literally going to lay down
and we're going to try and line up
exactly like we did last time to see if
we're all good to go and then we'll
figure out starting which I assume will
be tomorrow it's a beautiful day in Los
Angeles today so I'm feeling good I'm
also drinking 3/4 caffeinated coffee
today I made half caffeinated coffee but
I forgot to dump out Elliot's full
caffeinated coffee so they mixed
together and I'm at 3/4 caffeinated
pretty caffeinated for all hell big so
we'll see it's always good to be the
most caffeinated you've been to go to an
appointment where you have to sit
extremely still and line up four dotted
tattoos on your body with radiation
beams yeah this is an ongoing process of
Education that's what sickness is an
oper
opportunity to learn that's what we're
going with today I got a
buer like a Cheesecake
Factory maybe I shouldn't have recorded
as well I have tea water for tea tea I
got back from radiation safety run we
are safe I have lines drawn on me I
learned uh more of the system of how it
works there how I imagine like when you
belong to a gym you know how the lockers
work and where the dirty towels go and
where you wait for this we start
tomorrow for Our 20day
Extravaganza I just came back and did
therapy on Zoom real quick cried a
little bit real quick about things good
things deep things meaningful things and
now I'm going to go over to mamories to
record this week's episode of this might
get weird oh she's busy
again yeah we're on to our first
official day treatment of radiation
listening to a playlist of the best hits
from 2010 to 2017 hell yeah day one of a
20-day radiation treatment let's
go so fast this time I barely had time
to change they called me back that was
so fast I'm
done
for oh my God see couldn't keep it down
you're Soo strong and healthy how you
humble and all sort of [__] go your bed
and you know it my best you let me time
show it oh my God oh my God that is
insane one of the sponsors of our
podcast is this company called songfinch
and they make original songs for
whatever you might need an original song
for and mayry got them to make a song
about me and oh my God that was the
first time I heard it holy [__] as I
come back from my first radiation
appointment oh my God that's so cute
thank you song Finch wow also radiation
ran really well I was in and out so fast
it was insane everything today is silly
and working out wow that song my God
that was so
cute I thought it was going to be so
cringy but it was so cute thank you song
Finch thank you mry oh my God good
afternoon I'm on my way back to Cedar
siai for the second time today I had
radiation this morning and now I'm going
to get my port removed from my
arm yeah Elliot's driving me CU I just
took an Adavan because they take it out
while you're Wide Awake it's incredibly
symbolic and significant that it kind of
marks the true end of not needing um it
for infusions like I did for chemo so as
surreal as everything is this will be a
very real procedure that confirms Ms
that the chemo is over I'll have to get
hormone therapy get an infusion once
every 3 weeks but that's very minimal
compared to the 5our sessions of chemo
so let's go let a doctor cut my arm open
while I stare at the ceiling and think
about other things exciting
right
Elliot beautiful day to cut my arm open
he now it's dark outside but I don't
have have a port in that arm
anymore crazy full circle moment all the
trees I'm trying to film the moon and it
went behind the trees aru
intern good morning it is
7:37 on a Friday morning and I am going
to radiation yay after getting my port
out my arm still wrapped up from last
night getting my port removed which is
like a hugely
symbolic thing like even the doctors
were asking what am I going to do to
celebrate and I was like I'm going to
celebrate by getting radiation in the
morning and then they were like what are
you really going to do and I was like
um I don't know I haven't really thought
about it when people get their ports
taken out it's like significant of it's
over you no longer have to be part
medical machine and have the capability
to be hooked up to to poison at a
moment's notice so it's amazingly
awesome hugely celebratory but I just
felt a little numb and not because of
the lidocain I was telling Elliot after
we were driving home that like it's like
a big M Stone it's hard to really embody
that though when I'm now in radiation
and going every day so it doesn't feel
like things are finished but there's a
little Nano pit that got cut out of my
arm God I can't believe they do that
while you're Wide Awake even more
symbolic because it was the same exact
doctor that put it into my arm initially
and when he had finished that the first
time he said I'll see you in 4 months
and that was so comforting to hear
because I was at the very beginning of
all of it I hadn't even figured out if I
wanted to shoot a video so it was very
comforting to hear someone so casually
and upbeat and confidently say I'll see
you in 4 months and he did a little more
than 4 months but he did and he has a
Cadence that reminds me of nor McDonald
for some reason so there's something
really entertaining and comforting about
that now we're going to radiation I'm
going to go down to Palm Springs this
weekend it's the last weekend that my
mom and stepdad are hanging out and
helping out with house stuff down there
so I'm going to say goodbye to them this
weekend God just some mild
emotional situations to be put
in but let's go um get some laser shot
at us just like that 20 minutes later
we're done we're going to our car we got
[__] put in
[Music]
here okay I made it down to Palm Springs
I am in the highball house wo guess who
else is here who's just sitting outside
enjoying the view in the backyard Look
whose house party I crashed look at
these two they're just out here being
cute as heck just enjoying the view
which is insanely beautiful did I
mention Diane Keaton is here oh also the
internet loves your new hairo it looks
so good Mother Teresa everybody big
round of
applause we're about to go out to dinner
in a little bit but the two of them were
just enjoying the view oh wait yeah
Bill's got her hat and just like that
look look at that oh my God
[Music]
amazing wow wasn't that amazing wasn't
that quite a journey my noport arm is
healing well I will be going back up to
Los Angeles tomorrow and continuing my
radiation treatment on Monday tomorrow
barflies on our patreon um our book club
is happening if you're interested we are
talking about remarkably bright
creatures at 2 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time there will be a live stream so sign
up for the might it weird patreon to
join the live stream that I'll be
hosting talking about a book wow other
than that I'll see you in whatever next
video I decide to make or try or attempt
or do thanks for watching I don't know